das ist schon eine sehr kritische
situation man muss ja auch als
hintergrund sehen dass wir bereits im
frühling und im sommer eine mehrmonatige
schließung der schulen und kitas haben
und das war viele kinder schon sehr viel
stoff verpasst haben dass gerade auch
die kinder aus bildungsferneren umfeld
dass dies auch da schon besonders schwer
hatten und jetzt kommen eben bahn noch
weitere schulschließungen hinzu und das
ganze addiert sich natürlich in der
bildungsbiografie ihres kindes wir
sprechen jetzt seitdem ist kona gibt
eigentlich schon oder zumindest seit dem
ersten login über schulen und darüber ob
sie offen bleiben sollen ob sie
geschlossen werden und vor allem darüber
wie die digitalisierung an den schulen
läuft und man muss ehrlich sagen den
letzten monaten ist fasst jetzt ein jahr
in dem wir hier mit corona in
deutschland kämpfen hat sich gefühlt
kaum etwas getan auch dieses mal wieder
viele schüler die berichten dass ihre
schulen technisch noch immer nicht so
weit sind um den unterricht nach hause
zu bringen
wo liegt da das versagen sind sich die
schulen selber sind es die
landesregierungen ist es unsere
bundesregierung wer hat nicht genug
gemacht dass die digitalisierung in
unseren schulen jetzt endlich auf dem
stand ist um eben dieses homeschooling
zu unterstützen
also ich habe schon das gefühl dass in
sachen digitalisierung einiges passiert
ist dann höre ich natürlich und überall
das buckelt das server überlastet
das ist nicht so funktioniert wie es
angekündigt war
dennoch muss man natürlich auch sehen
gerade kleinere kinder ich selbst habe
drei kleine kinder zwei davon besuchen
die grundschule
da hilft uns digitalisierung auch nicht
viel die kinder die die kleinen kinder
die brauchen ihre lehrerin und die
brauchen die mitschüler schule ist ein
ort wo die persönlichkeit auch umfassend
geprägt wird wo sich die kinder weiter
entwickeln und wenn man ihn all das
nimmt dann ist das schon ein riesiger
schaden den man da anrichtet ein schaden
noch übrig die man im gegensatz zum
beispiel von schließungen von geschäften
von restaurants die auch sehr heftig
sind aber trotzdem der schaden der bei
kindern angerichtet wird ist ein schaden
die man finanziell nicht kompensieren
kann
und deswegen ist für mich schon die ganz
eindeutige forderung die schulen
insbesondere die grundschulen die müssen
diesmal mio
geht haben frau schröder sie kennen die
politik nicht in einer krise aber sie
waren ministerin sie wissen wie s da
hinter verschlossenen türen zugeht wie
um entscheidung gerungen wird wir haben
vor ein paar wochen einmal eine
geschichte gehabt zu der frage wie viele
schulpflichtige kinder eigentlich die
jeweiligen ministerpräsidenten und
minister haben die da entscheiden
da waren nicht viele dabei spielt das
eine rolle dass sich da einige politiker
vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr in die
lage versetzen können wie es mit
schulpflichtigen kindern ist und das
dann einfach gesagt wird ja das ist ein
infektionsrisiko und deswegen muss es
nicht bleiben
also was mit sicherheit eine rolle
spielt ist wie sehr man mit kindern zu
tun hat so kinder in enger verbindung
hat dafür muss man ja nicht notwendige
eigene kinder haben viele gibt es ja
auch die vielleicht über ihr comeback
ihres umfeldes in kontakt zu kindern
haben aber das ist dann doch dann ist
natürlich wie diese diese verbindung
sagt einem schon wesentliche dinge die
sagt einem zum beispiel des hofs bowling
das sogenannte und arbeiten dass das
nicht möglich ist zumindest nicht mit
kindern ich sage jetzt mal unter 8
jahren
wie können sie mal wenn sie glück haben
20 minuten vom ipad packen und ihn
pepper potts an machen aber dann war's
das auch schon wieder
es funktioniert nicht zu arbeiten die
kinder zu betreuen und sich auch noch zu
hause um die bildung der kinder zu
kümmern das geht alles mögliche den bach
runter und das ist einfach der schaden
den wir sehen müssen wenn wir jetzt
wieder sagen schulschließungen müssen
sein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren